Oh là là… 72°C !
Pas de panique ! C’est la température du gazon tondu.
Je l’ai volontairement entassé au fond du jardin.
D’où vient cette chaleur ?
Nous sommes pourtant à l’ombre.
Depuis plusieurs jours, des microorganismes
dégradent la matière organique et se multiplient.
Cet activité, comme n’importe quelle exercice
génère de la chaleur,
qui sous cet épais manteau végétal,
ne parvient pas à s’échapper.
Au contraire, la température monte.
C’est pas plus mal !
Au-delà de 70°C un bon nombre
de microbes pathogènes ne résistent pas...
Il y en a un que je mettrais bien là-dedans !
Il y a même des ingénieurs qui songent
à utiliser ce phénomène pour chauffer des logements.
En tout cas c’est suffisant
pour chauffer une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés, mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Pour être sûr de n'en louper aucune
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confiné et on reste en lien.